a translation acting on the coordinate
plane takes the point negative 169 comma
434 to point negative 2 O 3 comma
negative 68 what are the coordinates of
the image of the point 31 comma negative
529 under this translation and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try to think about it on your own so
let's think about what the change in X
that this translation does and the
change in Y that this translation does
so our change in X our change in X is
going to be our ending point our ending
point so negative 2 O 3 minus our
starting point - negative 169 minus
negative 169 and this is the same thing
as I'm surrounded in yellow negative 2 O
3 + 169 which is the same thing as 169 -
203 I'm just writing it this way - for
my brain to process it which is the same
thing as the negative of 203 - 169 and
let's see this one is the easiest for my
brain to process this is going to be 34
so this is going to be negative 34
that's our change in X now let's think
about our change in Y our change in Y is
our ending point is negative 68 negative
68 and our starting point is 434 so our
ending point minus our starting point -
434 is going to be equal to so this is
just going to be the same thing as the
negative of 68 plus 434 and let's see
430 plus 60 is 490 plus another 8 plus 4
plus another 12 so that's going to get
us to 502 this is going so this is going
to be negative 5 oh - so this
translation what it does is it shifts us
in the x-direction by negative 34 and it
shifts us in the y-direction by negative
502
so if we're starting at thirty-one comma
negative 529 we're going to end up at
we're going to end up at let me write it
this way so if we're starting at this
point we're starting at 31 coming
negative 529 we're going to end up at 31
minus 34 minus 34 that's how much we're
going to shift it and negative 529
negative 529 so negative 529 - 502 - 502
so what's this going to be 31 minus 34
is negative 3 and then if we have
negative 5 29 minus 502 that's going to
be negative
1031 so that is where we end up we end
up at the point negative 3 comma
negative 1031 under this point gets
mapped at this point under this
translation